peur ou maria rim voici deux tartines
est donc capable de reconnaître celle
sur laquelle j'étais retiré du beurre et
celle sur laquelle j'ai tartines et de
la margarine difficile de se prononcer
la texture et la couleur sont identiques
et parfois même hors où on peut se
tromper et pourtant ces deux aliments
n'ont rien à voir aller aujourd'hui dans
sur la planche j'étale ma science je
vous raconte l'histoire étonnante de la
margarine
[Musique]
première différence entre le beurre et
la margarine le beurre est un produit
autrement dit il est élaboré à partir
d'un seul ingrédient le lait en
l'occurrence la margarine elle est en
revanche le résultat d'une recette qui
combine plusieurs ingrédients très bien
je note doucement ce n'est pas la seule
différence le beurre est obtenu à partir
de matières grasses contenus dans le
lait il s'agit donc de matières grasses
animales la margarine est élaboré à
partir de matières grasses végétales de
l'huile de colza ou de tournesol
enfin aujourd'hui car ça n'a pas
toujours été le cas
la margarine est une invention 100%
française qui date du second empire par
1869 napoléon iii alors au pouvoir est à
la recherche d'un produit pour remplacer
le beurre l'empereur veut trouver une
alternative qu'ils puissent mieux se
conserver ils souhaitent ainsi fournir
la marine française qui part en
expédition pendant de longs mois ou
encore les familles plus modestes
un concours est lancé donc voici le
lauréat
[Musique]
hippolyte meije mouriès alors ce nom ne
vous dit rien à l'époque il est connu
pour ses travaux dans l'agro alimentaire
en particulier sur la fabrication du
pain napoléon iii lui a même remis la
légion d'honneur en 1861 pour l'ensemble
de ces contributions et ça ça compte pas
pour du beurre pour trouver un substitut
au beurre mais genou riez commence par
étudier la composition du lait de vache
sur la base de ces observations il
parvient à reproduire en laboratoire une
texture proche de celle du beurre il
utilise pour cela de la graisse de boeuf
ka riffier produits qu'ils baptisent
margarine du grec margaron qui signifie
perle à cause de sa couleur nacrée la
margarine aînés je ne comprends pas tu
n'as pas dit que la margarine ceux
fabriqués à partir d'huile végétale
minute papillon met pas la charrue avant
les boeufs j'y viens justement
habitués depuis des décennies au beurre
et aux produits laitiers les français
sont perplexes l'académie de médecine
est même saisi par le ministre de
l'intérieur de l'époque pour savoir si
cet aliment est vraiment ça ceux qui en
font des caisses enfin des tartines sont
surtout les élus des départements de
l'ouest les premiers producteurs de
beurre ils ne voient pas d'un très bon
oeil l'arrivée sur le marché d'un
produit concurrent est plus abordable
que le beurre résultats en 1897 la
margarine est tout bonnement interdite à
la commercialisation de la pensée que
certains se sont fait graisser la patte
ça on ne sait pas quoi qu'il en soit
elle la margarine n'a pas dit son
dernier mot si en france elle est
boycottée à l'étranger elle passe crème
à les dérives sont les archives
ou pays-bas l'industriel sinon
vandenbergh spécialisée dans le commerce
du beurre parvient à mettre au point une
recette réalisée à partir d'huiles
végétales très vite les journaux vente
le succès de la maria rinne que l'on
bâtisse désormais le beurre populaire
voici un extrait d'un article paru dans
un journal français le panthéon de
l'industrie monsieur von den berk
commerçant hollandais fut un des
premiers à voir dans l'invention de
monsieur meije mouriès l'application
pratique d'un problème dont il avait
toujours cherché la solution tandis que
d'autres continuaient à attaquer la
maria rinne comme une matière entier
génique préjugés qui a persisté
longtemps dans une grande partie du
public mais que l'on peut considérer
aujourd'hui comme définitivement vaincu
c'est donc là bas aux pays bas que se
développe la margarine telle qu'on la
connaît aujourd'hui et si on essayait
d'en fabriquer nos aussi
pour fabriquer notre margarine maison il
nous faut de l'huile végétale
tournesol colza et de l'huile de coco il
nous faut également de la poudre de
moutarde un peu de citron et de jus de
carotte on commence par mélanger les
huiles pour stabiliser le mélange on
ajoute ensuite un émulsifiant un jaune
d'oeuf par exemple qu'on fait dans la
mayonnaise ou comme ici de la poudre de
moutarde quelques gouttes de jus de
citron pour la conservation un peu de
jus de carotte pour la couleur il faut
maintenant refroidir brutalement le
mélange pour le fixer c'est l'étape de
la cristallisation on le plonge dans un
grand saladier rempli de glaçons et on
continue de fouetter et voilà regardez
le mélange s'est pacifié il s'est
cristallisé notre margarine est prête
beurre margarine cébron paume un
organisme bien si les deux produits se
ressemblent leurs propriétés et leurs
intérêts nutritionnels sont différents
le beurre apporte de la vitamine a à
l'organisme mais il apporte aussi des
acides gras saturés dont la consommation
excessive favorise le mauvais
cholestérol c'est pourquoi il ne faut
pas en abuser ne pas le mettre à toutes
les sauces comme toutes les matières
grasses d'ailleurs la marine elle est
riche en vitamines et contient des oméga
3 et 6 qui sont naturellement présents
dans les huiles végétales comme le colza
et le tournesol il s'agit d'acides gras
essentiels au bon fonctionnement de
notre corps l'organisme ne peut pas les
fabriquer c'est pour cette raison qu'ils
doivent être apportées régulièrement par
l'alimentation de plus les oméga 3 et 6
ont un effet reconnu sur le maintien
d'une bonne santé cardiovasculaire
mais il est important que le ratio soit
équilibré l'idéal c'est au maximum cinq
fois plus d'oméga 6 que d'oméga 3 au
cours d'une journée
aujourd'hui la margarine peut
parfaitement être utilisé pour toutes
vos préparations du quotidien qu'elle
soit salée ou sucrée de la même manière
qu'on utilise le beurre est à
performance égale il faut simplement
veiller à ce que la mention cuisson
cuisine soit spécifié sur l'emballage en
effet certaines margarines aux promesses
sont est bien spécifique contiennent des
nutriments plus sensibles à la chaleur
bon eh bien il ne reste plus qu'à les
préparer mes épinards et cette fois ce
n'est pas du beurre que je vais mettre
dedans mais de la margarine et vous que
cuisiner vous avec la margarine
indiquait le mois en commentaire bon
appétit et à très bientôt les épis
curieux
[Applaudissements]